"Naruto" is one of the most popular manga of all time.
But after 15 years, American publisher Viz Media has announced...
...the series will come to an end this November.
It would also be ending in its native Japan.
The final installment of "Naruto" will make its appearance...
...in the November 10th issue of "Weekly Shonen Jump."
Masashi Kishimoto's long-running manga first appeared in 1999.
Viz Media clarified, "Don't worry."
"The graphic novels are still coming out and the anime has a long way to go."
"The story in the manga is coming to a conclusion,..."
"...but the world of 'Naruto' is still going strong."
"Naruto" has become one of the best-selling manga worldwide,...
...spawned many anime films and game adaptations.
The latest Naruto film, "The Last: Naruto the Movie,..."
...is slated to hit theaters December 6th in Japan.